foreign
there's a new movement in the
Financial world the banking world to do
advertising with a narrative of how much
they're here to help
when a bank says they're here to help
you should act like the government
saying they're here to help okay you
should say oh my gosh I mean so let me
give you an example if you you know Sofi
spent 300 million dollars last year on
marketing and advertising with sweet
little people
on the screen going we're trying to get
out of debt and we're working our way
out of debt you know what sofa does
they sell that
hello is this thing on
hello are you out there
you know what we call that Dave we call
that a catfish
like
with no mustard yes catfish with no
mustard parading around as one thing
when really you're it's like a wolf in
sheep's clothing yep
it's like a cat pretending to be a fish
just saying yeah you're exactly right on
the catfishing thing catfishing on uh on
Instagram will get you banned from
people's lives that's right catfishing
when you're a bank is a way of doing
business man
here's another one rocket mortgage oh
they're just fast they're a rocket I got
it Dave we gotta get into this rocket
mortgage this is the headline that came
across our desk this is so great rocket
mortgage launches a credit card
to help you save or pay off your home
which everyone knows that works I mean
it's really let's be honest Dave it was
only a matter of time
so they no I mean I
when you're sitting there in the meeting
with the Ad Agency
what are you guys smoking
that comes up with this byline for a
press release because this is a byline
from a press release the CNBC then
picked up rocket mortgage launches a
credit card to help you did anybody not
go this is like standing in traffic will
not get you killed
gosh it's a saving up for a down payment
and closing costs is a major hurdle on
the the path to home ownership oh boohoo
the new credit card from mortgage lender
rocket companies aims to help buyers
eliminate it so they're saying hey you
know what it's not going to be hard
anymore it's not going to be hard you
can use a credit card you just borrow
your down payment
on our credit card you can earn lots of
points oh five x points on and oh here I
love it because now the dumb people in
the world are going to go 5x points yes
I definitely want to put my down you
know my down payment on my credit card
because I get 5x points on it and guess
what you get to do with the points
pay down the mortgage wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute the dog just
Chase its tail the dog chased it yeah
yeah he's going in circles he ate
himself so we wait a minute we we got
points that aren't real anything to use
to pay down on the mortgage to cover the
down payment that we didn't make because
we use the credit card to get the points
oh my goodness it's like the dog chasing
its tail isn't it it's like when you go
to the carnival
and they go which which cup is it under
and they move and they move it where's
the p boys and girls wow I'll tell you
where it is rocket mortgage is peeing on
you that's where it is oh my God it says
okay so five you this is what you get if
you sign up for the rocket Signature
Visa card you get five rocket reward
points on all purchases
sounds like I'm in kindergarten I know
right I get Rockets Mommy I got three
rockets today and this is probably the
one that it just sounds dumb it just
we're talking about down payments
mortgage payments real money here and it
says but you get the 95 you know dollar
service fee waived
all right you get 95 guys great
they waived their fee that's too high
yeah
annual fee is 95 but they've you know
what I'm gonna waive my fee too
um I didn't have one until a few minutes
ago but now I've got one and I'm gonna
wave it I'm not gonna charge you guys to
listen to this show it was going to be a
hundred dollars but we're gonna wait
we're just gonna wave You're such great
customers y'all are amazing and so we're
just gonna wave that here we go intro
APR none but the regular APR
I don't know if I can even say this
without screaming it
20.49 and it's variable so it can go up
to 30.49 APR which just stands for added
pain and regret all right you're you're
using your credit card
pay down your home loan added pain and
regret that's good 30.49 variable you
may as well have went out and just
oh gosh this is the worst thing I've
seen in a long long time Dave
well credit needed not specified
yeah
um this is
the thing about this is it's so funny
because it's not even subtle it's just
it's just pretty much announcing we're
gonna screw you and here's how and
you're gonna you're gonna like it
they're not even you're gonna enjoy it
this is they're not even trying to I
mean when they said credit needed not
specified they're here to help you yes
we're here to help you James said in the
booth he said this sounds very
incestuous I said yes because we're
we're getting you
rocket mortgage we're getting you the
loan that you could never afford in the
first place and then because we know you
could never afford it in the first place
we're going to help you by giving you a
credit card so you can put the down
payment on that you could never afford
in the first place and help you pay the
payment that you could never afford in
the first place and we're just we're
good guys and we're here for you I
thought he meant when he said incestors
that your parents had to be cousins for
you to fall for this that might be true
too that might be true you need to be
missing brain cells in order to think
that this is a good idea son freaking
believable oh man oh man oh man guys
y'all aren't even bashful about screwing
your customers I mean you just come
right out and say it we're just gonna do
it like 30 percent interest yeah right
there man just step up we got you back
maniable wow it's just there is no limit
to their but there is a generous reward
rate on all purchases there's lots of
generosity involved here
I just I smell generosity all over this
wow yeah this is a steaming pile of you
know what catfish catfish rotten catfish